[Music]
Len Goodman control you know it's a six
they know Tonioli radio I don't do any
mistake
[Applause]
what was your first experience on a
dance floor like honestly amazing I'm a
little bummed because it wasn't my best
I think I had done it better before but
I'm still really happy and I'm so
thankful to have him because he going
and he's an amazing teacher an amazing
friend so this experience is just
incredible and first weeks time
[Music]
week one how'd you do she the amazing
chach out of the way it's pretty hard
dance I got voted off the show with the
cha cha
I'm just letting you know thank God for
that but she's amazing you know again
it's hard to perform a life in front of
everybody and find the cameras fine you
know and keep it rhythm and keep the
technique going and be on time and all
that but she the heel she she was
awesome she was awesome so proud of you
and I'm looking for sin actually I can't
wait we've got these walls which is
ballroom and I'm not gonna tell you
those the other it's two dancers but
you're getting married she'll marry next
oh this is great prep for the first
dance
I mean definitely yeah I fiance here it
was like he was with me before and I can
see him right now he's waiting for me
out there no yeah